you have an obsession with Star Wars
like a lot of nerds but because of their
audience yeah but because you work in
this business you've actually had the
chance to meet some of your Star Wars
heroes from childhood is that right yeah
I haven't met Harrison Ford lucky for
him because I will I will hug him so
hard he probably won't be able to move
and but I met mark hey I'm on a couple
of times super cool guy but the best is
Carrie Fisher so cool like one of my
first crushes and and you know and I've
loved her forever and so I got to meet
her and she's super nice as you know
yeah and she's tiny though she's very
tiny and I'm very very large and so we
were taking a picture and she apologizes
for her size she goes oh I'm sorry I'm
so little and I go oh my wife is
actually five two just like you and she
goes oh a spinner yeah
nice mouth princess interviewed her just
I mean she was the same way she was just
possibly saying they're the raciest
absolutely hilarious now growing up was
your room filled with Star Wars toys I'm
imagining it was just chock-full no I
don't want to get sad but no I was
raised by a single mom we didn't have a
ton of money so I didn't get boohoo I
didn't get all the toys I wanted but I
had to make do so this happened I one
morning in my bathtub I was reenacting
the classic scene from a new hope the
battle between the original Star Wars
art yes
between Vader and obi-wan Kenobi but I
only own to obi-wan Kenobi a figure at
that point I'm in the bathtub so
standing in for the Dark Lord of the
Sith was my ten-year-old penis
how does that work it has a helmet yes
it does yes yes no I just looked at mine
in a long time so no one has anyway the
point is so we're going at it
what no we're going at it
so obi-wan is fighting your penis yes he
might win this one he might turn it
around and and then he doesn't have to
be a force ghost spoiler but but my mom
all she sees when she walks through our
tiny apartment and me and our tiny tub
and I'm like this like rock oh yeah my
mom freaked out she's like what are you
doing
and I was like I'm just playing Star
Wars you know and I I hold up Cano
because Vader wouldn't stretch and it
seems like oh okay that she backed off
and then I was like well she was really
upset so what was what could I have been
doing so by my mom thinking she caught
me masturbating she actually taught me
about masturbation and Radek Lee I
masturbated to Carrie
okay
I tried things together I'm a
professional there get on that story you
act like you're in the tub and all I was
doing was taking this obi-wan doll and
having it battle my penis when my mom
misunderstood she didn't misunderstand
anything it's a freak show I think now
if seeing you masturbate would have been
a relief yes exactly yeah he doesn't
even know what to do with that
you